how is everyone doing today
[Music]
you know why there's a lot of excitement
and i saw the silent praise
because i know what this means recently
and i'm doing it more and more um you
guys are excited because
we are celebrating something on friday
we are celebrating knowledge we are
celebrating
uh uh chemistry
and um we are we are celebrating how
much we've learned in the last month
it's called exam three it's a midterm
yeah
thank you for that where over that and
uh and and here oh and so so what you
know
what i thought we'd do today instead of
uh again
i mentioned this on monday i instead of
it you know you
you guys just had thanksgiving uh you're
back and now we got a test
and i know you got a lot of other stuff
going on too at this time so instead of
throwing something in that we're not
going to test you on
what i wanted to do with today was just
to kind of feel our oneness
with the concepts right and so i want to
kind of go over the concepts that
are going to be potentially on exam
on the exam on friday and we'll do
uh you know i'll talk about those
concepts and we'll do a couple of
problems here and there as we go
okay so those are the the metrics the
specs
for exam three now i wanted before
so that's what the top but on monday uh
i finished with two minutes left and i
said hey there's one more kind of
acid-base definition
you won't be tested on it but it's the
most general and i got to give lewis his
due
so i just wanted to you know just show
you like that
you won't be tested on lewis acids and
bases but but we did
i did throw this in there and so i want
to just for one or two more minutes talk
about this
right these are the things you are
responsible for know yet so an arrhenius
acid base
oh h plus bronsted-lowry uh
it's it's proton transfer and then
there's lewis who broasted these guys
because he said uh-uh and and this
is the most general way to think about
acids and bases
it is the most general it is um it is it
is quite powerful
um because now you go back to say
this one right and and so if this is a
a uh what what if we mix this with this
right uh so here we have h now remember
lewis had all the dots all over the
place he loved dots
and so they're all over the place and
that's what you know if you had this
this is a lewis acid because
it is ready to receive what is it ready
to receive
no more atoms only electrons it is the
most
general way to think about it right
and this would be a lewis base because
it is ready to give a pair of electrons
and form a bond together and that's what
they do or that's what they can do
so lewis acid and a lewis base are the
most general
is the most general form and you really
get rid of so for lewis you really
it's all about electron transfer
electron pair
transfer pair transfer
or bonds if you're well let's say elect
i'm just going to make it as
general as possible if you're going to
mix an acid in a base which i'll do in a
second
it's a pair electron transfer
is what it's all about and
you know what what happens here well you
don't you don't have any chemical
identity
no more chemical identity
so it's it's full you don't need the
hydrogens anymore you don't need the ohs
it's totally general and and this really
opens it up because now you can look at
gases liquid solids all forms of matter
all elements in the table and you can
think about them as whether they're
going to have
an acid-like or a base like character in
terms of electron transfer
so you know here's the general if you
had a lewis
acid and a lewis base and you mix them
together
then you can see that if you got an
electron pair
that could then go that one of them
wants it and the other can give it and
they can form a bond
then that would be how you think about
mixing a lewis acid in a lewis base and
again
i'm not this won't be on the exam but i
just had to
give lewis his due okay
lewis acids and bases are all about the
electrons
and then the other thing i didn't get to
do on monday was my why this matters and
so i want to do that now hair
is very much affected by the softness of
water
and instead and and so but instead of
you showing
instead of me showing you lots of
pictures of hair
that i found randomly on the internet uh
googling soft water hard water
you know different forms of water hair
i'm showing you pipes because that's
much more actually uh
relevant in terms of like for example
whether you can get water into your
house
at all right and and this is a real
problem
if you have hard water what it means is
you've got minerals
in in the water right things like
magnesium and calcium ions
are in the water and what happens is if
you run that through pipes
they tend to react and form and deposit
right and you get these deposits of very
very hard mineral deposits around the
edges that eventually
look like this that's not a good thing
and so you need to
soften the water and that's something
you may have heard of
but now you really know how to think
about it because you can think about it
in terms of all of the things that
you've learned
and just as as an example if you it you
know if one of those minerals that's a
problem is calcium
oh it is right magnesium is another one
uh that that can cause this in pipes you
you gotta you gotta somehow take it out
of the water or at least
make it into a form that uh that makes
it like insoluble so it'll just flow
and it won't have a chance to come
around and and and deposit
on on in you know on the edge there of
the pipe and so
what do you do well you add for example
oh we've done this before right what if
i add soda
something called soda ash well we know
what that is
that's na2co3
and that will give me some ions
it'll give me some n a pluses and it'll
give me
some co three two minuses
and those are in aqueous solution you
know this is this is all part of stuff
that we've been talking about right
you're dissociating this to get ions in
solution but why do i want these ions
that's a water softener why because now
you you can see it right because this
one here
this one here is going to remove the
calcium
and so if i've got these calcium these
minerals in the water making it hard
water which leads to that
and wreaks havoc on your hair then you
you you get a little of this in there
and you're gonna react with the calcium
why but it's because of what we already
saw right if i
if i have this this is something we've
already looked at if i have calcium
two plus and i have some bicarbonate in
there
co3 minus then we know
that i can get precipitates ca
this is just what we looked at in the
goody bag right plus
co2 and plus h2o
that's the same uh kind of reaction that
we looked at already with calcium
carbonate
right calcium carbonate why well because
this
is going to give me these this is a
source for those
which then eats up some calcium
and you say well now this can this can
take the calcium ions out
so that it runs through that's what you
want to do here
that's how you soften water well you can
add lime
which gives me a source of o h minus and
that takes out the magnesium
right and these are ways to change the
chemistry of water so that you don't
have as many ions
mineral you know these calcium and
magnesium ions floating around
that cause problems so that was my why
this matters
and now we turn to what i started with
which is exam three
oh look at that i look at that and
that's just
you know that's happiness look at all
those topics
x-rays xrd defects
glasses reaction rates solubility
aqueous solutions acids bases
it's all there it's all there and it's
and it's all
there in you wait and if not you've got
two days
so please make it be there
let's go through this let's go through
this i'm gonna go through this top right
click so i'm gonna tell you kind of the
concepts that i want to make sure you
know
and then uh and then we'll okay so
here's the first one so it's x-rays
and xrd so what do i want you to know
well for example i want you to know
about how you have
characteristic characteristic
characteristic uh
x-rays and remember this this is
this comes from those transitions right
so you got like the k
and the l and the m
we say etc we never really did etc but
you know we got a lot of k
and l lines we looked at right
alpha beta
but there's also the continuous right so
this was in
if you want this would be in the topic
of x-ray generation
and there's that brim strolling
word that means breaking
right so if you if you just want to look
at this
you might have a curve that looks okay
so we had things like this right
oh i'm gonna try to make it not look
too bad right and there's another one
and so on and and remember
yeah so this would be like intensity
intensity and this would be like
maybe uh lambda going that way or
or maybe energy energy going that way or
frequency
right this would be like like the x-axis
and and these are those lines those are
the lines right and they come from the
transitions
that you get from like the k level to
the l level to the m level right
remember you're not
you can if you get the energy high
enough
of an incident electron onto a target
metal then you can knock out electrons
from that 1s
shell and then something cascades down
and that emits these lines here
right so it'll be like k alpha k alpha
k beta et cetera but then you also even
at lower energies
even if you don't have enough energy to
knock out a 1s electron
you still can slow an electron down as
it goes through a metal atom
and that's where you get this continuous
spectrum right
and that that limit of how how much of
that type of x-ray you get
it just depends on the incident volt on
the voltage right
on the the maximum incident electron you
fire at it so that's those first two
topics
okay uh well oh we also
did uh x-ray diffraction
oh that's fun diffraction
okay and this involves understanding
brag
right the brag condition and
also selection rules
so let's do let's just take a look at an
example of the of the diffraction and
selection rules okay so what
what would i want so these are like the
kind of concepts that i want you to know
about
how might it play out so like um okay so
here's like
here's an example of a spectrum now
that's an x-ray spectrum
for uh mgfeo4
magnesium ferrite and and it's a kind of
steel
right and you put it in you make a
powder of it and you and you throw some
x-rays on
it oh no you throw just one type of
x-ray on it
right so for these x-ray spectra what
happened i threw some k
alpha on it i showed right there you got
to say what you got
right there you got you got to know at
least okay the source of x-rays
has this has this wavelength good
and if i have that spectrum and say
what's the lattice constant
well what's the structure i can get that
how would i get that
how would i get this so i would take
this spectrum
and notice something is very much
pointed out to me
a peak and a number 35.5
right that's the that's the two theta
value for the three one one peak
well i think i'll take that as a hint
maybe i should think about that number
and i show okay so let's see from bragg
so from bragg
you know that
you got n lambda equals
d equals 2d sine theta
and remember that had to do with
constructive and destructive uh
interference of waves the waves being
the x-rays and
and then we said well n is n is one in
our class okay so we're gonna
that's just one in 309 one it doesn't
have to be you could
you could have interference off of two
planes down three planes down but in
this class we're just doing the two
planes next to each other so n is one
okay now i'll take that angle
and i'll round it to 18 degrees so i'm
going to say for theta
equals 18 degrees
then uh oh wait why is it 18 and not
there
because that's two theta right because
remember we met we take spectra and two
theta but the theta in brag is one theta
okay that wasn't too hard and so then
but now i got uh let's see
uh sine theta
is around 0.3 and so if you
but oh i got lambda lambda equals
1.54 nanometers and so i can actually
plug in now
i didn't even need the peak i'm just
plugging in
the brag condition right and i've got d
d equals 2.5 to angstroms
so i'm done no no
i'm not done because the question says
what's the lattice constant
what's the lattice constant this d i
didn't say
i did something very bad i didn't say
what d d is in h k l
that's what an xrd does x
xrd is that's a different d then
diffraction but
the d in brag is the distance between
the the mirror planes that are
scattering all right
and so that's some cuts in the crystal
that's some hkl and we know from that
era that there is an equation
for cubic crystals that gives us hkl
which is a divided by the square root
of h squared plus k
squared plus l squared and that is
the lattice constant of the crystal
right and that would be the distance
between any planes
any set of planes in the crystal okay
and that's what we need
now i can i can use that combine it with
with the the d and i can get that the
lattice constant is 8.38 angstroms
good the second question
is you don't even need to do anything
any math to answer that
what is the lattice structure here
we simply go to our selection rules and
we know
from before look if they're all you know
if if they're all even or all odd
so here we have let's see all these
peaks 2 2 0
3 1 1 4 0 0. you can see they're always
all even or they're always all odd
from our selection rules what kind of
crystal is that
it's got to be fcc right
it's got to be fcc so that that's that's
the answer to that question
right just from looking at the peaks
that you get and
and and matching them with the selection
rules that you know
that we've already talked about
you could also you know if you didn't
have the planes
so this is the this is an example where
you're given all these planes you're
given all these hkls but what if instead
it's like the one we had in class
we went through this in class here i'm
not given the planes i'm given
instead just two theta values
well now you got to go and use the
procedure
of xrd and i'm not going to do that
again we've already done that
pretty thoroughly um but but that's what
you have to do here right
where you create your columns remember
the columns right
so so so you would simply make your
columns you make your sign
your your thetas that is your two theta
theta
sine squared thetas and then you
normalize right you take the lowest one
and and you normalize to one
clear fractions and then find the hkl
combinations and that's how you would go
from this to getting for example the the
planes
okay so those are some examples of
things
i want you to be able to do with x-rays
and xrd let's move on
let's go to the next topic let's do
defects how about this
defects because as we said
it's just like life crystals defects are
what make them interesting
it's the same everything it's all about
defects imperfections that those are
the interesting and exciting things so
we got to know about them in chemistry
of course then so
we we talked about a bunch of different
kinds of defects the first one that we
talked about
were vacancies okay
vacancies and these could be you know
interstitial they you could also have
these fall into the category of point
defects
point defects right
you could also have also interstitial
point defects
interstitial or
substitutional
right those are the different kinds of
defects we talked about
for point defects also by the way if
it's an ionic point defect
ionic point defect
you need to make sure you have charge
neutrality charge neutrality
plus two types
there's frankel and there's shocky hey
you think about
is it shocky you remove
but you got to remove them in a way
that's charge balanced
right so in shock you remove uh uh in an
ionic crystal you got to keep charged
that's the new thing
you got to keep track of and so so if we
had i'll go to the
this uh this picture oh you should know
this picture
this is an important picture we showed
it a lot right vacancy
interstitial self-interstitial
substitutional but and then if it's
ionic
now the sudden you got charges in there
and so you just got to make sure things
remain neutral right in shock you would
remove
atoms to balance the charge and in
frankl
you move an atom
that shocky remove frankl move
just occurred to me that that's
the same word with just read in front of
it
that's exciting oh so if i were to ask
you for example if i were to ask you
this
you diffuse chromium
into one side of the ionic crystal
alumina
to make it red and titanium on the other
would you expect
oxygen vacancies illumina vacancies are
no vacancies
in each case just follow the
follow oh follow the charge
follow the charge so for example if i
had aluminum
alumina o3 well if i were lewis
we started by time if i were lewis i
would see this as
2 al right 2
al 3 plus right this is how he saw
ionic bonds uh three
i want to make sure this is clear i'm
gonna start over
so i would have two
al 3 plus and then i would have a 3
o 2 minus remember o likes to be 2 minus
and so if i were to introduce something
like
cr203 well
you know this also this is two
cr three plus so this is two cr3 plus
and three o two minus so
you know if i if i substitute aluminum
with chromium then i'm charge balance
right i'm okay but if i substitute
titanium
right tio2 is ti
4 plus and
2 o 2 minus you know this just from the
formula
because if oxygen is 2 minus this
thing's got to be neutral and so that's
ti4 plus
but now if i if i put a ti in there and
i get one in for an aluminum
i've knocked the charge by one
right so this gives us
an extra charge
and that means you got to create
vacancies create
aluminum vacancies it's the only way to
do
it it so for every three titanium atoms
that i put in i got to take an aluminum
one out
right otherwise i just i'm not going to
have charge balance
not going to have charge balance right
so that would be an example
of uh of of kind of playing with an
ionic crystal but you know remember we
also had stress strain curves
because
when we talked about line defects we
talked about how that's a way for
metals well and other materials to go to
undergo deformation and then we said
well how are we gonna
how are we gonna conceptualize uh
you know these things happening and we
did it with the stress strain curve and
the mechanical response of materials
so we learned about stress strain curves
and
uh you know fracture points
fracture and
plastic versus elastic
uh regimes okay i'll give an example in
a sec
okay
and finally the last thing we did with
defects is we talked about their
activation
and so we know if something is thermally
activated
as our point defects
well the vacancies are are are thermally
activated so are
other types of point defects and and we
said that we need an arrhenius
relationship
and that requires knowledge of an
activation energy for the defect to form
so that was another really important
concept that we covered right and so
so for example um here you know here's
like a defect
formation energy question
so uh let me go over here stay with
these
this side where i've got some defects um
so uh you know one thing i want to make
clear
the fraction of vacancies we talked
about this the fr
somewhat an arrhenius behavior arrhenius
like behavior
and the fraction of vacancies was the
number of vacancies over
the number of possible sites that makes
a lot of sense
now if it's a radius then this is some
constant
times e to the minus activation energy
divided by kbt
it where we use the boltzmann constant
if it's per
atom right so per vacancy
that activation energy would be per
vacancy uh but
and when i first introduced this i
simply let a be one
but a is a constant this is a constant
and it can be it can be whatever it's a
constant it's called the entropic
factor uh
and it's a constant related to as you
would have in any arrhenius-like
behavior
right remember how it's like a frequency
factor
right this is related to all sorts of
complexities that we don't need to know
about
related to how vacancies form i mean
it's a constant that's in there and i
let it be one but i want to make sure
we put it in explicitly now this yeah
okay
so what's the this n
is the number of possible sites right so
maybe it's the number
of lattice sites in the crystal
a number of possible sites but you might
get it
this could be related to can relate
to for example okay or to or from
things like the grams that you have of
something
right or maybe the volume
or the moles etc right so these are kind
of the kinds of problems we've done
now that gives you a sense of how many
sites did you have
right it could be per centimeter cubed
it could be per you know per moles you
can go back and forth it gives you
how much stuff do i have right is that
kind of back and forth
if i had a problem like this then i know
i've got
i know i can set it up because i've got
two temperatures
you see the key here the concentration
of 10 to the cube
per centimeter cubed so don't let that
throw you off it's simply
two equations where a bunch of stuff
cancels
right so the fraction of vacancies
fv one would be 10 to the third
divided by fv2 and that's going to be 10
to the third
over 10 to the 16th because
the n the number of stuff cancels
right i didn't change that oh but this
pre-factor cancels two
you can put it there right a times e to
the minus e
a divided by kb
times 300 kelvin remember it so it was
kelvin
divided by a times e to the minus e a
divided by kb
times the other temperature 900 kelvin
right and so those cancel the the
you know the stuff related to n cancels
and i can just take the number
of vacancies right so that's what's nice
about having something like this you
have two temperatures
and a whole bunch of stuff can cancel
and you can figure out
then the activation energy which doesn't
change
the activation energy is simply the
energy that you need
right so you can now solve
for ea and i think you get something
like 2.3
electron volts remember that you could
also have plotted it
you know that in this in this equation
in the iranian relationship if you take
the log
right and then you have a minus 1 over t
relationship so if i wanted to get the
sl
right so remember that so if you take
the t
versus the log then you're going to get
that
right we like plots
when we think about arrhenius because it
makes it easier we can make it linear
right where the slope of this is minus e
a
the slope minus e a over kb
in this case right so we talked about
these are all kind of kinds of things
that we talked about
and finally getting to the stress strain
what you know what if we looked at this
this is the stress strain so now we're
here
we just did this we talked about that
talk about this so
stress strain so if you were to add you
know if you were to be given floss like
this you know
which one is most brittle which one is
the stiffest right
the most resistant to changing uh
elastically and which one is the most
ductile
well you can see that the stiffest one
is going to be the
one that's the most resistant
to elastic deformation that's that
linear part that first part
so there it's going to be material a
right it's going to be a because it's
got the highest slope
right okay how about the most brittle
well that's the one that's going to
break
so it sort of looks like you know
without deforming without being able to
undergo deformation that's brittleness
it's going to crack before doing
anything so that's b
right that's b and then the most ductile
will be the one
that has the most plastic deformation
because that's what ductility is
and so that's going to be c
okay so remember stress strain curves
right you got this
this elastic part here that's linear and
then
if it's a material not all materials
have
plastic deformation some are going to
break before they
they start deforming plastically but if
it can deform plastically then it's
going to have
that yield point right the yield stress
where then it starts becoming non-linear
and then finally it fractures somewhere
else
right okay so those are stress train
curves
okay let's move on
now oh with uh
the next topic oh boy i'm gonna run out
of real estate we got glasses
and here the most important thing to
know about
is the curve that's how it all started
right i'm calling it the curve let's go
all caps
because it's the curve and
what i mean by the curve is the volume
per mole
versus temperature we also talked about
the the effects of cooling rate
and we also talked about the effects
of modifiers
right and in particular how that how the
modifier
changes the viscosity because it cuts
the pasta
okay and so but that the framing of
these concepts was in the curve
and that's this one oh i have a pl i
have a picture of it there it is
okay okay they did specific we do volume
per mole that's how we're looking at in
this class so volume for mole versus
temperature
now remember if it's a if it's a crystal
where am i going to go let's go here if
it's a crystal
then you've got one melting point that
only depends
on the material okay it only depends on
the material so that melting point is tm
and and it's gonna have a big volume
change
as it goes from liquid to
crystal solid okay and so for example
you know i'm just basically re-plotting
it but
you would have something like this and
something like this
and something like this and that's your
melting point
right and this would be the liquid and
this would be the solid
and you know that if it's going to
undergo this big volume change
then it's the melting point it's a
crystal all right
uh but then we say well but if it can't
fight chris by crystal
i mean in opposition to glass which we
know
doesn't just mean your windows it means
any amorphous material
meaning it's not crystalline it didn't
find the lattice structure
the atoms remember those three reasons
the musical chairs
whatever you're trying to crystallize
atoms or molecules they weren't able to
find all the lattice sites
not even withstanding some defects here
and there they simply couldn't do it and
so it's amorphous
and it's a glass and in that case
what happens is it super cools and
then becomes a solid
at something called the glass transition
temperature which unlike the crystal
can have different values and those
values can depend on things
like the cooling rate right so if i cool
it slower
ah if i cool it slower
right this remember this is faster
faster slower and please
do not confuse time with this axis this
is just temperature
so we can use the same this is volume
per mole
we can use the same the plot you know to
think about modifiers
as well because it's not this this is
just
one plot one curve and another this
happened to be cooled slower because and
so it was able to super cool
more before it locked in the disorder
and the other one was faster but if you
you could also imagine if you cut the
pasta
you you change the viscosity right
and and so now you're changing something
else about the glass using chemistry
and you're allowing it to find those
lattice sites more easily you're
allowing it to try to become crystalline
to try to close pack just a little bit
more
so you can also get this by cutting the
pasta you can get these kinds of changes
right so those are the things
we talked about with glass now
next we talked about reactions
okay
what do we need to know about reactions
reaction rates
so we want to know the order
right of some general reaction like a a
plus b b remember this goes to
c c plus d d
and we want to know the rate
the rate from basically it's the the
mass conservation right so from the
coefficients
okay so that would be for example like
minus 1 over
a d a dt that's a rate equals minus 1
over b
db dt etc
now those come from the coefficients but
the rate law does not
the rate law does not so
these are simply instantaneous rates but
now i say no i want to rate
law that gives me the dependence on
these
on these uh uh
these concentrations at any time
and so the rate law so the rate law
would be for example uh okay like rate
equals k times let's say a to the m
b to the n now here's the thing
these these
come from experiments
very important distinction right those
come from experiments
and and so you could get the rate with
respect to a which would be
i'm sorry the order with respect to a
would be m
the order with respect to b would be n
and the overall order of the reaction is
m plus n
right the overall order
so that's why and then we had one more
item here of you know conceptually what
i want you to know about
which is that the rate also depends on
temperature
sorry the rate constant rate constant
depends on temperature so
if i were to now say well okay i want to
know something about the order of a
reaction
you might get a table like this and we
did this you know in class
you might get a table just like this
here's a reaction it's w
and x and y and it goes to z
don't let the fact that you have three
reactants throw you obviously
you've got a certain number of reactants
they've got their coefficients and they
go to some product
okay and now you're given experimental
data
so from this data you can get the order
of the reaction
with respect to each one of these right
and that would then give you of course
the overall order
right so let's see if we were to look at
that data
then what what would we get
so what you want to do in these kinds of
situations
is
first of all don't panic oh by the way
on an exam
in general don't panic and if you have a
question you can ask a question
and but also show us what you know
we will give you as you i hope have seen
already we will give you as much credit
as we can
for sharing what you know you don't have
to get everything right to get a lot of
points
please share your knowledge
so in this case what would the knowledge
be well it'd be that i want to compare
stuff like trial one and two
and and if i do that you see okay trial
one trial two
then two of them stay constant but w
doubles
okay so comparing
one versus two you got
w goes to two
two times but the rate is same
so you know the order the order is zero
with respect to w but if i compare
1 versus 3 then
you know that let's see x
goes to 3x and the rate
goes to 3x and so the order
is 1 and then finally for y
i will just jump to it the order
is 2. and you can do that just by
find one where only y changes you don't
have to necessarily
find one where just one changes right
because if you knew one
is first or you know if you knew one and
then you had another one and they both
changed but maybe the rate didn't change
then you know they must have the both
the same order if they change in
opposite ways
right so you can get into this in
different ways just looking at
these changes from one to another and
thinking about
what must happen in terms of the rate
law in terms of what you wrote out
here okay
but you could also you could also ask
questions like
like you know with reactions like okay
this is first order
what's the dependence of the
concentration over time as a function of
the rate constant
well that's uh you know that just goes
back to our
understanding of the integrated rate
equation right
and so let's see oh boy
now i need to find i'm gonna go
i hate to do this xrd i hate to do this
but
sometimes being first carries a
consequence
okay uh so you know in this case
first of all by the way you look at
reaction like that you're like well okay
from the coefficients in the mass
balance stuff
you know you know that the change in
oxygen for example with time
the instantaneous rate would equal minus
the change
in mo2 right
with time well that's not what the
question asks the question says it's
first order
so that's enough because
the in the the rate law if you integrate
a first order this means
that if i integrate the rate law
then first of all if it's first order
then d
of m o two with respect to time
must equal some constant times the
concentration
of mo2 to the one
right first order and so now if i
integrate this
i take this concentration over here i
put the dt over there you integrate it
right you've got all the integrated rate
laws
we've gone through this already you know
that you get
that the log oh we do logs
of this mo2
equals the log of some starting
concentration
minus kt okay
why do we do that because we like
plotting things linear things
we love linear
so you know you remember we did this we
went from these these integrated rate
laws to plots
and back and forth and so that's also
very important
okay now finally okay so the last couple
of things
so and and these i'm purposely giving
these last ones a little less time
because
they're the ones that we've seen very
recently and these are the ones that we
haven't seen for almost a month
right yeah but you still got to know
about
solubility
and so for solubility remember what we
did is
we did equilibrium and
le chatelier
and we did the equilibrium constants
the k's like for example
ksp is the solubility product solubility
product constant right
and then we also did ice tables
and then we talked about the common ion
right and so as an example
you know if i were to say well okay i'm
going to take uh why is bacl2 i might
have done this one in class
why if i add bacl2 to a saturated
solution of baso4
why does it cause precipitation that's
the
common because answer because of the
common ion effect
well you could write these out right so
you write out your
your saturated solution right so you
write out your baso4
and you see that ba so4 solid
will go to ba
two plus in solution plus
so4 two minus in solution and
and so the common ion effect tells you
that if i
if i now add something else that has
something in common with one of these
that gives me
an ion in common then because of le
chatelier you're going to drive
the reaction the other way that
precipitates because it forms a solid
bso4 so i've just done that right i've
given you bacl2 which gives you a source
of ba2 plus
and how do you figure out if you were
given amounts
what happens what the new equilibrium is
you use ice right you use the ice tables
right okay and then finally
we talked about acids and bases oh
i really hate to erase defects but here
we go
defects are gone arrhenius i'm so sorry
that was painful and the last
topic here is acids and bases and this
is the most recent one
and so what do we have well we've got
the
acid equilibrium constant the base
right we did water we did ph
oh we did p anything right p
equals negative log of the thing
uh pka pkb
so so okay so we could have uh
and then we did like for example the
definitions right so
arrhenius versus bronsted-lowry
lowry definitions
right and so so for example if you're
given a solution this is one just simple
example right
of an acid and you and it's hocn and
you're given the acid and you know the
ph
so you're given that then the ph
the ph from that information you can get
that the concentration of h plus which
is also h3o plus
is 1.7 times 10 to the minus 3
moles per liter right that's from the ph
and if you have that then you can go to
the
ka definition which is
h plus concentration
ocn minus divided by
the acid ohcn concentration
and you got it all because if you write
the the equilibrium
equation which is what ka describes
the equilibrium of this acid
dissociating into ions right
dissociating into h plus and oc and
minus and so you can get ka
okay so what i hope is that this got us
in the mood that this got us all kind of
on the right page with respect to these
topics you've got two days
you